oh boy another day making YouTube videos
I wonder how many subs I have today
where do they go
where are they why socialblade what
happened
how could this happen
I used to have 46 million subscribers
this is outrageous I used to have 46
million where are they
even keemstar lot stubs that way he's
always losing subs evens accepting I
lost EPS what is happening YouTube I
need answers I see how it is YouTube
you think this is some kind of game
600,000 people poof I'm shaking YouTube
you know you know you did not just do
that YouTube
not after all this [ __ ] YouTube
sometimes clear subscribers aren't
inactive I'm sure that's what happened
it's usually not that big but I'm sure
that's what happened YouTube would not
fail me YouTube know what's going on
with their own website clearly they
understand how it works we know many
creators are seeing a loss in YouTube
subs we're looking into it and we'll be
sure to share more when we know more you
don't even know you don't even know how
did this happen
I've never been this pissed off since
the diamond play button and
like a couple days ago I lost [ __ ]
sex on Dredd that's like damn mark
come back to me Dan Marc rest in peace
600,000 people this is worse than that
one time I didn't get the diamond play
button even though I was supposed to get
it
they say it's normal that it goes up and
down you're telling me it's normal with
600,000 people just going away is that
normal you what if Dan Marc went away
would you just not care I mean I
wouldn't [ __ ] Dan Marc I'm just kidding
damn Mike I love you that's how you're
treating this really we take the
relationship between our content
creators and their subscribers seriously
[ __ ] no you don't don't even say that we
recently discovered a bug that prevented
changes in subscribe it was a bug you
telling me it was a bug a glitch we have
removed spam subscribers from your
channel you're calling my subscribers
spam now YouTube is that word is that
what this is going they're all spam to
you they're not spam to me
I care about my subs I'm not just in it
for the money
YouTube wants to take away the diamond
play button from me
this is just the beginning they're going
to start 600,000 the next day it's going
to be a million the next other day it's
going to be a billion and then poof I
won't have any subs and no diamond play
button
[ __ ] you YouTube I will not give you the
satisfaction I'm doing this [ __ ] right
[ __ ] now I'm so pissed god damn it
I'm so pissed you brought this on
yourself YouTube
you brought this on yourself
it doesn't go down come on I need you
I'll need you okay that's disgusting
right my Michael can you clean it okay
yeah thank hold that thing more than I
love Edgar make sure it's polished okay
I don't want a spot on it there's [ __ ]
on it you have to link it up okay okay
you actually thought I would flush down
my diamond play button I got an extra
one don't worry about it this is the
real one it's got my name on it
okay YouTube stop deleting subs or I'll
delete you you know I can I can I can't
do [ __ ] what should I say I'd still need
two more though what's up with that
thank you so much for watching this
video
stop deleting my subs hit subscribe
twice let's [ __ ] with the system hit
subscribe twice let's see what happens
maybe we get the oldest subs back do it
right now and I'll see Bros in the next
video I would kiss my brofist but I
think it's a little gross cuz it's
pretty but stay awesome brush